sind ja alle hilflos letzten Endes wir
wissen der UNHCR berechnet also bis bis
2050 mit weltweit 200 Millionen
Flüchtlingen aus aus Klima Gründen aus
Kriegsgründen aus armutsgründen so
irgendwo zwischen einer Million guten
Millionen die wir im Jahr schaffen und
200 Millionen auf der Welt die wir ganz
bestimmt in Deutschland nicht schaffen
können liegt ja die Wahrheit und wir
kriegen das im Moment einfach sehr sehr
schlecht sortiert in der Tat also das
Asylrecht ist überhaupt kein
vernünftiges Einwanderungsrecht für
Arbeitskräfte das funktioniert nicht die
Probleme in der Praxis liegen natürlich
auch daran dass wir zum Teil die Leute
auch wenn Sie hier strafbar sind und
raus müssen nicht zurückgeschoben
kriegen weil die jackensländer nicht
kooperieren insofern ist natürlich alles
was danach mühsamer Diplomatie und
Politik klingt dass man irgendwie
versucht sich mit den Leuten zu einigen
und zu sagen wir machen also
bewerbungszentren schon in euren Ländern
und wir versuchen das vorher zu klären
und dafür es gibt also eine legale gute
Chance nach Deutschland zu kommen dafür
nimmt aber eure Verbrecher auch bitte
zurück das ist alles richtig aber es ist
alles wenig das sind kleine Zahlen
und das Problem ist einfach die
Bevölkerung trägt es langsam nicht mehr
mit und auch dazu gibt es eben geben
umfragezahlen auch aus der vergangenen
Woche von Allensbach die das immer
liebevoll also im Detail sich angucken
also 60 bis 60 Prozent in ganz
Deutschland in Ostdeutschland sogar 70
Prozent sagen wir können nicht mehr
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen 50% wollen das
Asylrecht geändert haben und 85 Prozent
sagen jetzt macht doch endlich mal ein
Einwanderungsgesetz das irgendwie ein
klares Signal setzt solche Leute wollen
wir hier haben
also in drei schnellen punkten wenn sie
Chefin werden was müsste in diesem
Gesetz stehen was mir keine Ahnung das
kann ich ihn wirklich nicht sagen es ist
unheimlich komplex und schwierig wir
sehen ja auch dass wir das vielleicht
der Fairness aber auch noch mal gesagt
also wir haben natürlich im eigenen
Umgang mit ausländischen Arbeitskräften
oder migrantischen Arbeitskräften noch
Luft nach oben also es gibt schon auch
gut qualifizierte Leute die gerne hier
arbeiten wollen und unglaublich
schikaniert werden von den Behörden ich
meine Vermutung auch so aus einer
gewissen Kenntnis der Praxis ist weil es
einfacher ist ordentliche Leute die sich
gut anpassen und was wollen noch ein
paar automatische Schwierigkeiten zu
machen als die richtig harten Fälle mal
zu verarzten also dazu gibt es leider
eine Neigung in in Bürokratien und das
ist glaube ich ein Teil unseres Problems
und wir haben ja Fachkräftemangel also
die die nicht also uns fehlen ja die
Leute und wir wissen es seit Jahren die
Jahrgänge sind heute halb so groß wie
auf europäischer Ebene haben wir dieses
Thema ja schon angeschnitten gehabt da
hast du auch angesprochen wir brauchen
da eine strengere Grenzsicherung absolut
die Bundespolizei Predigt das auch wie
gesagt seit gut einem Jahr Frau ferser
aber sie will das einfach nicht hören
und dann ist immer die Rede davon wir
können unsere Grenzen nicht zu machen
die Außengrenzen werden aber auch nicht
vernünftig geschützt teilweise sind
andere Länder muss man sagen innerhalb
Europas auch sehr unfair die dann
einfach sagen die deutschen schaffen die
Anreize dann geht doch auch durch die
wollt doch gar nicht zu uns wir sehen
das momentan auch mit der Schweiz ganz
extrem die Leute wirklich Interesse
gesetzt durchleucht hier aussteigen
diese Richtung bitte gehen das ist aber
dadurch natürlich entstanden weil wir
Deutschen dieses Gefühl vermitteln wenn
wir nehmen alle auf und deswegen kann
ich das unterschreiben dass er gesagt zu
verschärfen denn wer einmal bei uns ist
das ist momentan einfach vergeben geht
nicht mehr denn uns doch noch mal eins
sagen auch die Justiz spielt da eine
sehr eigenartige Rolle
Verwaltungsgerichte Leben zum Beispiel
Rückführung nur nach dem Dublin-Abkommen
nach Italien Griechenland momentan ab
weil dort die Unterbringung und
medizinische Versorgung nicht so gut ist
wie bei uns also muss ich mir vorstellen
kann demnächst auch jeder Grieche und
Italiener also wie beantragen weil es
ihm da schlechter geht als bei uns ich
meine das hat überhaupt gar keine Logik
mehr dann sind alle Abkommen wie Dublin
und ähnliche Dinge absurd weil sie sie
funktionieren hinten und vorne nicht
mehr und wenn wir 300.000 Menschen hier
haben die einfach nicht zurückgehen und
ich habe ja kürzlich erst beschrieben es
gibt wirklich die werden aufgegriffen es
steht drin im Computer sofort
ausreisepflichtig dann wird versucht
eine Ermittlungsrichter zu erreichen der
sagt ich habe keine Haftplätze hier in
Berlin sind sehr geschlossen der
Flughafen Macht zu mit dem
abschiebebereich es gibt ja gar keine
Plätze vor Faser schließt die letzten
sogar noch und dann sagt man es gibt
keine Plätze wir können die nicht
abschieben dann kriegt ein Zettel in die
Hand melde dich bitte am Montag bei
deinem Ausländeramt sozusagen zur
Abschiebung an ja dass der da Montag
nicht aufläuft wissen wir alle das heißt
wir haben kein funktionierendes
Rechtssystem mehr und da ist ein
riesengroßes Problem weil sagt die
Menschen merken das und da kippt
irgendwann die Stimmung und das kann im
sozialen Unfrieden ändern in den keiner
will nur sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung das
kann ich Wahnsinn jetzt melden unsere
Reporter kümmern sich um Ihren Fall
vielen Dank
Bild kämpft für Sie